i mean i i don't know much about asia i
just i i know the names of the countries
in some of the history and here you are
in japan
and now you're learning you're uh
educating yourself
about things i knew about the history
but that's about it
he knew the history
we colonized this
[Laughter]
yeah is that part of my collaboration it
sounds really like we would name it like
yeah
you know
i appreciate the english
because often you would hear about
countries and it was always like it was
like 50 50. i'm like did we
no
history is really cool when you learn
about it but i was just saying you
should never got taught in school in the
uk because they were like that's that
far away place that you'll never go
because europe and butlins is an hour
away so yeah but at least you guys got
to learn about like european history
right which is like oh well [ __ ] that
though european history is such a
[ __ ] mess is it yes dude better than
australian history we only have 250
years and most of it is racist yeah but
at least you can say like
true but at least
i don't think europeans are any better
in terms of that literally white men
come to person's land take land away
here we are today and then dump the
prisoners yeah but you're on a bunch of
politicians blah blah blah here we are
like [ __ ] 900 years arguing about who
is the best white person yeah but at
least you guys had like you know like
wars and like colonies and all that
like cool [ __ ] yeah
like the romans and like the byzantines
and like all those like that shit's cool
there's one movie about australia and
it's called australia
isn't it isn't it
yeah it's nicole kidman yeah nicole
kidman
that's cool though you can learn all of
your history within like a reasonable
amount of time yeah but like as a 14
year old learning about like politics
and [ __ ] i'm just like i i don't care i
i don't know most of european history i
don't know history was like that one
class that i just never paid attention
to it's true
i don't know about it i don't know about
it like the most the most world history
i know is from the [ __ ] video from um
bill wurtz
that's that's
to be fair i learned a lot from those
videos yeah i did i did learn a lot from
because i just never paid attention in
uh history class because i don't know i
love him but i wish i could learn like
you know about like the japanese history
or you know like actually about like a
history of a country that is like you
know i actually i think japanese history
is interesting
i think i think chinese history is
interesting i wish i learned about that
stuff like that yeah that's 4 000 years
of history that you can look back on
right now because that's [ __ ] cool
that's like so much history and it's
just like one place as well where it's
european it's just like is it the romans
this time like where is it greece well
europe like every [ __ ] fight i know
right literally like on the dot what
percentage of like the history of
classes that you took or had that's your
question actually in high school or
middle school
was that
was dedicated to european history versus
i mean it was it was all european
history well wasn't it
what other history did you learn
american
i did not learn anything about
we learned american and chinese history
what did how did they teach american
history i was mainly uh the civil uh the
civil rights period right covered 50's
space space yeah the generic the space
race the highlights you know the
highlights of the modern american
history that isn't that they like to
tell because it sounds good it's like we
beat racism
it's ended
beat the russians
you know like uh that kind of stuff yeah
i never learned about it china was just
like um
i don't know i don't know which one is
the correct one because there's multiple
pronunciations of like mao
mao said there's mao zedong which
because which pronunciation is correct
because we got we got taught a bunch of
different things there's like 20
different associations or something as
well i don't know which one's correct
every british person trying to like
pronounce chinese words yeah i'm
terrible we've learned about that
see that's cool though because like we
had in australia at least in my school
we had ancient history which was like
about like the
we didn't do any ancient history
egyptians that kind of stuff that's
that's what we learned and then we had
modern history which was about like
world war one world war two vietnam war
we did so much on world war two yeah
life feels like because british people
love world war ii yeah they [ __ ] love
of course they do like
like literally like they're like they're
like look guys we we beat the odds
yeah cause like i i only remember world
war one and world war two being taught
in my school it's like we i think we
were taught a bit of american history
but it was just very glossed over
i don't know why so i don't know why it
was glossed over it was like for at
least for me i don't know if it was we
have gcses which are like when you get
to
age 16 you can pick three or four
subjects yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah one of
them was history i chose so that's why
it's history that's why i did we learned
american history and chinese history oh
okay because the most i did but the
generic one was just like world war ii
yeah i i did the generic [ __ ] i've only
done the generic [ __ ] up to gcse which i
didn't even pick oh i was just always
like trench foot this is bad you know do
you have accelerated like history
classes too like ap honestly no we don't
do that in the uk we have the only one
that has it is math we have advanced
mathematics right yeah yeah yeah yeah we
have that further maths you know oh is
it further further yeah
i know because i took it okay
that's the only subject
in the uk
who would have thought the two asians on
the podcast accelerated mass
accelerated math yeah we called it oh
god speed running
accelerated myth yeah we yeah al's is
called accelerated math is that like
trigonometry or something no
trigonometry is the basic stuff yeah
trigonometry you you had to like pass
trigonometry
as to to get to further math accelerated
maths was like you know like like
three-dimensional graphs and yeah
imagine imaginary numbers
and stuff like that but i i did notice
like when i compared what i learned to
school to what sydney learned at school
at the same time especially with maths i
don't know if it's just because i was
like i don't know if it was like the
education system but i would notice that
what i learnt was like way before what
sydney learned in school sometimes and i
don't i don't know if it's like i don't
know how the education system works but
then i also know that compared to asian
asian schools they are like way further
beyond what whatever i [ __ ] learned
in school like that is everything they
were doing like college level maths in
high school and i was just like what
yeah like in japanese schools you learn
long division at like fourth grade
and i'm like what i didn't learn that
[ __ ] till i was like 16. [ __ ] is long
division long division is like divide 72
463 by 275 so [ __ ] though because you
know we everyone uses calculators
nowadays you don't have to [ __ ] know
this [ __ ] did you guys have like
placement tests for math yeah you did
okay
how was it for you oh yeah we had
placement yeah and then oh man like how
did you place
i don't remember when it was good at
maths
i guess maybe yeah kind of
i suppose yeah what did you plan
no how dare you
wait what what subjects did you excel at
at school
like what did you what did you take
what did i excel at at school were you
no at anything yeah 4.0
but you were good at school i wouldn't
say it's good what
what what
you talking about like people are
getting four point ones and stuff
because they do like good you can tell
she grew up in an asian family
extracurricular activities right i
thought 4.0 was the highest it is but
then you can get higher if you do
extracurricular yeah every every single
true crime documentary is always like he
was a good kid he had a 4.0 gpa after
harvard yeah
absolutely cut off that one with arms
and legs yeah pretty much
yeah i think the highest math i got to
is like algebra 2 because you can choose
to stop yeah right and i just chose to
stop and then fill it with other courses
so wait what was like your favorite
subject in school favorite subject yeah
art
maybe yeah i got to make like pasta
sculptures i i loved art because i would
ask myself well i can imagine it's like
[ __ ] macaroni
did you have like are schools like
well-funded were you friends i would say
yeah well barry uh
is pretty everything
all the parents donate money oh
okay like someone i found like one of my
aunts
constantly donating money to her
daughter's school because it just
makes the program much better
the government's not giving enough money
so the neighborhood parents are just
giving money wow i remember when i did
like badminton there was only like two
rackets out of 30. the word broke
i mean that's that's just like school
equipment school facility but like
like like the the wiring is [ __ ] up
yeah that's the point where it's like
you just yeah play backwards yeah we had
like 40 acoustic guitars and only two of
them worked oh my god
this happens don't [ __ ] get me
started on textbooks like when when the
[ __ ] teacher says all right time to
get out of the textbooks i'm like who
who who am i sharing with today like
like huddles around yes right yeah
because like like in my school like
to like when when you were reading from
a textbook i you everyone needed to
share at least with one person so
everyone had a partner like a textbook
partner yeah yeah
yeah
but not by obligations because like half
the class had just forgotten their
textbooks so it just became like a
tradition to be like
it's my turn now do you have cooking
classes in america yeah we have cooking
classes it's like home egg or something
we're cooking class as well
i never took it because i hated oh we
had no choice oh really did you have to
cook in school nope they made this great
yeah we had to do it for one year yeah
oh they made us cook and they made us
you won't believe what one of the dishes
was we'd prepare a sandwich
that was no joke one of them
british cuisine
your bog standard lunch box sandwich and
when i told my mom she had to buy me
ingredients to make it she was so
insulted that she complained to the
school
i mean i would be that's a waste of an
hour she was like i'm not buying
ingredients so he can make a [ __ ]
sandwich
right now how about i just make one
i made a quiche and i think it turned
out to be an omelette or something that
that's that's common yeah yeah like that
happened i was like i'm never cooking
again egg egg just anything that uses
egg turns into a different egg dish it's
just halfway through the process every
time i don't like that many egg dishes